woher kommt das ganze wasser auf werden
tatsächlich eines der spannendsten rest
unserer erde hat es irdischen ursprung
oder kam das wasser aus dem all auf die
erde
nun gibt es eine neue studie dazu dass
der ursprung allen lebens demnach mit
gigantischen mastställen aus dem
weltall zu tun hat und welche
gesetzmäßigkeiten dafür leben im
weltall bedeutet dass jetzt endlich zum
tanzen fiction herzlich willkommen
wie die erde entstanden ist darüber
herrscht in großen teilen der
wissenschaft konvent man ist sich einer
meinung doch ein teilaspekt dazu
nämlich die sogenannte wasser frage
wird unter wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen immer und immer
wieder neu infrage gestellt und
diskutiert denn so klar es ist dass ein
großteil der erdoberfläche mit wasser
bedeckt ist so unklar ist wo um himmels
willen das ganze wasser der ozeane
flüsse und seen und der eiskappen
eigentlich verkommen nicht einmal final
geklärt ist ob es auf der erde selbst
entstanden ist oder ob es aus dem kosmos
stammt und wie soll es dann wohl auf die
erde gelangt sein ein rätsel das
gleichzeitig auch den ursprung allen
lebens und somit auch unsere existenz
beinhaltet super spannend ist deswegen
nicht nur das aktuelle studienergebnisse
auch arizona auch die vorhergegangenen
versuche vieler verschiedener
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
eine plausible antwort auf die große
über allem stehende wasser frage zu
geben ist von spannung und dramatik kaum
zu überbieten zu vergleichen
tatsächlich mit einem krimi immer auf
der suche nach neuen indizien um der
frevel endlich zu lösen wie so oft gibt
es auch bei der wasser tragen zwei
verschiedene lager einige forscher und
forscherinnen vertreten die these dass
die erde seit ihrer entstehung wasser
enthält und das wasser in unseren
ozeanen und füssen aus dem inneren des
planeten stammt demnach soll das wasser
schon von beginn an in dem material
enthalten gewesen sein auf dem die erde
vor langer zeit einmal zusammenklumpen
das wasser weil zunächst im gestein
eingeschlossen und seien dann als gas
aus dem magma ausgeströmt und flüssig
geworden es ist die erste hypothese zum
ursprung des wassers auf der erde doch
liegt unser erster näht dafür nicht
viel zu nah an der sonne würde die
hitze der sonne
die entstehung solch gigantischer
wassermassen auf der erde zu lassen oder
würde ihre intensive strahlung ich dazu
führen dass der großteil des wassers
sofort verdampft was zudem gegen diese
erste hypothese zum ursprung des wassers
auf der erde spricht ist die annahme
dass sich die erde in ihrer frühzeit
vermutlich in einer wasser freien region
des sonnensystems nämlich im inneren
der mars umlaufbahn
kunden haben muss das argument der
schneegrenze führt dazu dass ein
großteil der wissenschaftler die zweite
jetzt folgende hypothese zum ursprung
des wassers auf der erde vor
demnach sollen aktuellen oder kometen
aus den äußeren bereichen des
sonnensystems bei einem aufprall auf die
erde
das wasser geliefert haben sowohl
kometen als auch aktien bestehen zu
einem großen anteil aus wasser so dass
tatsächlich keine krassen einschläge
von nöten gewesen sein müssten um die
menge an wasser die sich auf unserem
planeten befindet bereitzustellen
doch die spannende frage lautet wo
genauen sollen diese kometen oder
asteroiden hergekommen seien ein
anhaltspunkt dafür kann die chemische
analyse des wassers liefern dass man
innerhalb von zu untersuchen asteroiden
oder kometen findet um das dann mit der
chemischen analyse des erd- wasser zu
vergleichen so war so das ziel der
astrophysiker klar formuliert finde eine
region im sonnensystem in der aktuellen
oder kometen mit einem ähnlichen
isotopenverhältnis vorkommen denn das
könnte dann gleichzeitig auch der
ursprung des terrestrischen wassers
seien im jahr 1961 kam übrigens zum
ersten mal die these auf dass wohl
kometen das wasser auf die erde gebracht
haben sollten nur um es voller zu
verdeutlichen seit 1961 sind schon ein
paar jahre ins land gezogen und noch
heute im jahr 2017 gibt es keine finale
antwort auf die wasser frage die kometen
theorie als antwort auf die wasser frage
über dauerte dann knapp mit 20 jahre
bis dann in den 80er jahren der
hallesche komet der aus der orten wolke
stammt genauer untersucht vor der
ergebnis kurz zusammengefasst die
zusammensetzung des wassers viva cometen
stimmt mit der wasser zusammensetzung
auf der erde überein das fazit der
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
nur ein bruchteil unseres wassers auf
der erde stammt wohl wenn überhaupt von
kometen aus der ortsmarke das ist diese
riesige wolke um unser sonnensystem noch
reichen diese befunde aus um kometen als
wasserlieferanten der erde aus dem
rennen zu schicken
der wissenschaft könne jedenfalls
weiter als max planck forscher mit hilfe
des weltraumteleskops herschel eine
gruppe von kometen identifizierten die
app quelle für das wasser auf der erde
durchaus in betracht gezogen werden
können die jupiter familie
jetzt auch die untersuchten das
verhältnis von schwerem zu
herkömmlichen wasserstoff isotope und
haltet euch fest die analyse dieser
isotopenzusammensetzung hatte dann
tatsächlich ergeben dass das wasser auf
diesen kometen mit dem wasser auf der
erde übereinstimmt dies ist ja wohl ein
starkes indiz dafür dass diese kometen
als außerirdische wasserquelle gedient
haben könnten
oder etwa doch nicht soweit nun also ein
paar der wichtigen meilenstein im
großen rettet und um die wasser frage
nun kommt eine weitere theorien zu und
bricht eine weitere lanze für die
aktuellen fraktion im fachblatt science
schreiben wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen aus arizona und
jetzt das wasser durch asteroiden auf
die erde gekommen seid die sich in weit
außen liegenden bereichen des
sonnensystems entwickelt haben müssen
dort außerhalb der sogenannten solaren
schneegrenze habe die sonne eine nicht
so hohe strahlkraft auf eis verdampft
die eben nicht anders als auf den
sogenannten jugend planeten wie der erde
der venus und dem mars die durchaus
näher an der sonne heranwuchs nach
berechnungen der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen kreisten diese
aktionen damals als schlampe um die
sonne und hatten zum teil mehr als 100
kilometer durchmesser bei ihrer
entstehung wurde in ihrem inneren wohl
auch das radioaktive aluminium 26 mit
eingeschlossen
denn dies war damals zu einer sehr
großen menge im sonnensystem vorhanden
die so entstandene radioaktivität
führte schließlich dazu dass das eis
der erste ideen schmolz und diese zu so
genannten kollegen konkreten erstarrten
eine mischung aus wasser und festen
gesteins körnern also und um es ganz
korrekt auf den punkt zu bringen schlaf
als einige damals auf abwegen mit der
erde zusammen breiten warten wir den
aktuellen studienergebnissen zufolge
aber noch mehr als nur wasser mit
lebenswichtige elemente nämlich wie
schwefel stickstoff und kohlenstoff sie
gleich alt wie das wasser selbst vorher
kaum oder gar nicht auf der erde
vorhanden waren die aber als grundlage
des lebens selbst eine ungeheuer
wichtige rolle spielen somit noch einmal
auf den punkt zu bringen ohne diese
elemente die nach ansicht der astronomen
und astronomen wohl erst durch die
gigantischen flamm bälle auf die erde
gelangt waren
dettl eben wohl nie entstehen können
was hört ein großartiger zufall ist
das wohl endlich die lösung zur
vieldiskutierten wasser frage es gibt
wissenschaftler kollegen und kolleginnen
die den aktuellen erklärungsversuch aus
arizona freundin für plausibel halten
denn forscher und forscherinnen konnten
bereits im vorfeld zeigen dass das
wasser in diesen kollegen konkreten wer
dem wasser auf der erde ähnelt und
wieder zeigt sich offensichtlich ein
naturgesetz ein naturgesetz der
entstehung von leben auf den heißen
entstehenden planeten kann es offenbar
überhaupt keine zutaten für leben
geben
sie bilden lediglich den gesteins kern
ist er entstanden müssen dann aus den
äußeren bereichen eines sternen
systems konkreten und kometen auf die
planeten stürzen damit die bausteine
des lebens überhaupt vorhanden wenn sie
bilden quasi die lebensspendende schicht
um den toten gesteins kern wahnsinn
welche gesetzmäßigkeiten sich daraus
ergeben würden wenn es so ist dann ist
eben wirklich der normalfall im weltall
wir können also gespannt sein wann und
ob wir andere leben auf fremden planeten
tatsächlich finden werden wir halten
euch dazu natürlich hier und auch zum
thema wie das leben auf die erde kam auf
dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau und hier geht es weiter zum thema
mit kam leben von kometen auf die erde
erdrutsch auf tory wenn ihr euch mehr
zum thema informieren wollt dann klickt
unbedingt drauf und ansonsten bestand
bleibt dran